mon
nous sommes à la confluence de la loire
et de la vienne encore en touraine et
presque en anjou depuis le plateau au
dessus de candes saint martin un paysage
de vale remarquable se dévoile
nous retrouvons jean louis géographe
chercheur et maître de conférences à
l'université de tours il nous propose
une lecture du paysage au travers du
temps il ya 15 millions d'années ici on
est dans une mère une mère très chaude
qui va former en fait ce qu'on trouve en
dessous c'est à dire de calcaire dans
cette mère l'a énormément d'animaux
marins qui vont produire par leurs
restes du calcaire qui va former
aujourd'hui du tuffeau sur le plateau la
vigne semble dominer un espace agricole
qui reste cependant fait de polyculture
ce vignoble est relativement 6 6 1 il
était une politique culture entre
vignobles et autre chose et à partir du
début du 20ème siècle pour des raisons
de spécialisation va dire le vignoble se
concentre plutôt sur le coteau avait des
conditions agronomiques qui ne sont pas
les meilleurs mais qui permet de
produire moins de fruits plus concentre
ans rue en sucre et donc forcément des
gens typique ce qu'on appelle des vins
du terroir à la fin du 19e siècle le
phylloxéra obligera un complet
renouvellement des vies le progrès la
mécanisation notamment imposeront une
modification des pratiques agricoles et
donc du paysage avant la crise du
phylloxéra la vigne en france était une
ville en échalas en appel
c'est à dire que chaque pied de vigne
était tuteuré sur un tuteur sur une
échelle à faire en pieux dardoise ou de
bois et après le phylloxéra avec
l'évolution technologique arrive le fil
de fer qui pâlissent tout ça et qui
entraîne la vigne comme on en voit
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui en une
évolution nouvelle c'est évident en
herbe et comme les
le vignoble est toujours légèrement
inclinée le l'herbage permet de retenir
et sol donc on n'entretient plus le sol
- la plante on rentre ici dans les
nouvelles manières de faire plus dans le
développement durable
nous quittons candes-saint-martin
prochaine destination azay le rideau
autres territoires viticoles
en chemin nous longeons la loire source
de vie et de développement
elle subira elle aussi de profonds
remaniements pour servir les intérêts
viticole le vignoble a besoin d'un
exutoire d'une sortie et la sortie se
fait par l'autoroute de l'époque et la
loi donc quand on pense à la loire on
pense bien sûr à tous les ouvrages
navigation seul port et son ours nous
sommes une part de vraiment c'est ligne
d'en face est étonnant ce induit donc un
ouvrage maçonné pour faire abattre
l'oissu du côté de la loire et donc
faire de cet endroit un endroit à co
stable
donc tout est complètement lié entre ce
qui se passe le coteau ce qui se passe
sur le bord de l'eau
après la crise du phylloxéra la
reconstruction du vignoble et de
l'économie viticole repose sur une
politique de labellisation
azay-le-rideau possède aujourd'hui 62
hectares d'un vignoble aoc touraine avec
leur arrive toutes les modernités de
l'époque
c'est tout ce qui est phytosanitaires
aussi bien les produits pour traiter la
vigne que pour l'alimenter et donc le
vignoble est né de cette période-là le
vignoble qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
aussi un vignoble n'est de l'ess
désarroi des avancées technologiques
technique chimique de la première guerre
et surtout de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
jean-louis rencontre louis jean
viticulteur installé depuis 2002 il
développe son vignoble en agrobiologie
et biodynamie est trop technique mais on
favorise ce monde bactériologique besoin
à rendre le sol vivant et la biodynamie
considère tous domaines agricoles comme
un organisme vivant autonome nécessitant
le moins d'intrants chimiques possible
quand on respecte le sol comme on le
fait en bio ou en biodynamie on on
participe
à recréer un sol vivant c'est l'objectif
d'ailleurs un sol dans lequel on va
trouver presque 7 tonnes d à l'hectare
de vers de terre qui vont bosser pour
nous de 8 et jour qui fonce donc
apporter tous les éléments nutritifs à
la vigne sans qu'on ait besoin de le
faire à leur place je me souviens que en
démarrant en 2002 en bio il avait fallu
au moins trois ans pour que le solde
soit couvert d'herbes trois ans énorme
je pense que la viticulture la manière
dont la viticulture a évolué depuis le
phylloxéra pourrait être un modèle pour
notre société pour le paysage
le vigneron c'est quelqu'un qui a su
s'adapter aux différentes crises et le
phylloxéra il s'est adapté il a créé un
nouveau vignoble en phase avec les
habitudes des années jean des années 30
bref phytosanitaires aujourd'hui on a de
nouvelles crises c'est l'environnement
pas comme un terrain qui arrive fait
attention à nous à nos enfants qui vont
jouer c'est cette terre est aujourd'hui
les vignerons commencent à s'adapter
c'est le bio ce jeu dynamique et je
pense que ça peut être un modèle pour
l'ensemble de la société et donc pour le
paysage notre regard sur l'environnement
questionnent de plus en plus le paysage
dans sa partie invisible l'eau l'air la
terre composante essentielle de notre
écosystème sont sans aucun doute des
enjeux environnementaux et sociétaux
majeurs